الفنون شنو هو جنون كما يقال دائما حطم
رجل في فلوريدا رقما قياسيا لاطول وقت
يعيش انسان وين في الماء تحت ضغط المحيط
تحديدا اسمه هذا الشخص جوزي
وامضى لتويه 74 يوم في منزله في قعر بحيره
على عمق ثلاثين قدمت في اليوم الرابع
والسبعين خلاص تناول دينهور وجبه غنيه
بالبروتين وقام بتمارين ضغط هذه الضغط
اللي يمارسها يوميا وخذ قيلوله لمده ساعه
ديتوري يخطط للبقاء حتى التاسع من يونيو
المقبل عندما يصل الى 100 يوم ويكمل مهمه
تحت الماء يطلق عليها اسم بروجكت نابتيون
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات